not do it every time brings it up yeah
you've been an [ __ ] since you've been
here bro what when i can't [ __ ] don't
talk about it like that no
i know we you just calm down dude all
right i'm gonna type on now yeah we
don't know you got me all right through
the whole episode okay okay we were
having a nice conversation
you got super jealous and got super eggy
and the vibes just went
oh eggy huh what's your eggie you look
like a [ __ ] egg dude right
i look like an egg right you know what
it's racist right because inside the egg
is yellow stuff you're saying i'm yellow
so you're you're you no you look like
you just got viral dude you got
cancelled dude you just called me a
[ __ ] egg bro you look like [ __ ]
humpty dumpty shut the [ __ ] up i look
like humpty dumpty yes like humpty
dumpty fell off the wall you fell the
[ __ ] off okay after mad tv which is the
only thing i know about yeah you fell
off i fell off [ __ ] wall
i am yeah my egg broke after med tv is
that what you're saying yeah at least i
was on the wall yeah that's true man
that's great that was sitting on the
wall right that must have been real on
the wall
nothing for you yeah i was three years
old
[Laughter]
i was literally playing with toys in the
sandbox happy right as i ever have been
yeah before i started meeting people
like you and literally monsters like
ethan klein right
no ethan's not a monster yes he is no
he's canceled every day and i'm sure you
probably do too but you're just not
popping enough that anyone sees this
[ __ ]
i mean dude you went from television to
a [ __ ] podcast yeah bro it's i know
it's dark it's freaking hard i mean
isn't it true that you're too scared to
perform live
yeah i am dude i mean i do shows five
times a week but okay well i've heard
rumors yeah yeah from the rumor meal
yeah yeah look at the lineups you know
every night
[Laughter]
i wouldn't know because i've never heard
no you wouldn't know because i'm really
in the comedy game you're not i'm not no
i'm not a comedian yeah yeah i would
never not in any game right but i'm in
the game yeah you're not no so don't
talk to me that way well guess what what
i'll talk to you however i damn i know
you will and the thing is what'd you
call me again empty [ __ ] dumpster all
right dude i'm going to call daniel day
kim it's almost like he's saying
i know you're not wrong yeah you're
doing ching chong dude what dude how
much are you paying this [ __ ] guy
unbelievable dude yeah yeah wait slides
him in the hundred dollar bill yeah yeah
yeah
i don't like you
i love it gilbert i don't like you and i
like you yeah yeah
you like the white guy right but you
don't like the asian men right but you
want the asian women no no sit down
sit down
sit down dude sit down relax dude and
don't [ __ ] push me off
my hair bro all right dude my bad dude i
think that we should hard reset with a
real
real hug
no you're hugging i'm not hugging him
right now i'm you're not hugging him
right now i will not oh i'm not hugging
you man yeah yeah yeah how about you
yeah yeah that was amazing see here's a
dude here's a dude first of all
i can press charges before you push me
bro right or what for what for pushing
me that's assaulted
i didn't touch you anyway um
one of my best friends ethan was just on
the line
and uh so here's the deal dude you
didn't even know his number dude stop
playing who are you [ __ ] kidding he
picked up for me did he not i don't know
what do you pick was that even ethan i
don't know is that another one of your
guys you pay
whoa see what i mean gilbert you know
what he's calling you a paid [ __ ] no